juguemos al juego de los ángulos aquí
aquí dibujé una figura extraña te daré
unos cuantos ángulos luego quiero que tú
averigües cuánto mide en los otros
ángulos entonces así que bueno quiero
darte algunos ángulos digamos que que
este ángulo aquí espero esté siendo la
herramienta correcta
digamos que este ángulo aquí mide en
este mide 56 grados 56 grados luego te
digo que este otro ángulo este ángulo
acá este ángulo grande mide 115 grados
entonces 115 grados y ahora bien lo que
me gustaría que tú averiguar así es este
este ángulo que ahorita voy a poner en
color amarillo
me gustaría este es el objetivo del
juego de los ángulos ok entonces quiero
que averigües cuánto mide este ángulo
este ángulo y bueno si eres valiente
ponle pausa al vídeo e intenta
averiguarlo así que si quieres que yo lo
vaya enseñando bueno está bien de hecho
puedo darte unos cuantos pasos luego tú
ya puedes lo puedes intentar vale así
que bueno pero ahora ahora expone al
pusiste pausa y te enseñaré cómo yo lo
hubiera resuelto esto de los juegos de
los ángulos
ahora cabe mencionar que ya tienes toda
la información necesaria todas las
herramientas necesarias para resolver
esto
bueno quiero quiero que seas bueno
resolver este tipo de problemas porque
son como la clave para pasar un examen
de admisión no pasará ni aunque se yo
pero bueno es muy importante eso sí que
no te quepa duda bueno de hecho aquí no
tenía nada una muy importante y valiosa
información estas dos líneas son
paralelas ajá me faltó decir eso que es
lo más importante esas dos líneas son
paralelas estaba pidiendo que resolviera
as a esto pero sin esa información que
es tan importante de hecho no hubiera
sido posible
cada que yo veo este tipo de problemas
yo simplemente intento encontrar a
encontrar la medida de todos los ángulos
que pueda todos en los posibles y
lentamente intentó llegar al ángulo que
quiero encontrar así que este ángulo
mide 56 grados y estas líneas son
paralelas y esta es una línea
transversal entonces que sabemos cuál es
el ángulo correspondiente a este ángulo
de 56 grados
es este cierto ajá entonces que sabemos
sobre ángulos correspondientes o líneas
paralelas cuando cuando tienes una
transversal ese ángulo también mide 56
grados porque ángulos correspondientes
son iguales así que bueno
también tenemos más información este
ángulo mide 56 también porque son
ángulos verticales y su ángulo
correspondiente también mide 56 grados
ahora bien este otro ángulo este ángulo
mide 180 menos 56 lo cual es igual a 124
grados y solamente te estoy mostrando
estas cosas que puedes hacer con
simplemente jugar el juego de los
ángulos pero en fin bueno primero dije
que estos ángulos son ángulos
correspondientes entonces éste mide 56
grados
ahora quiero saber cuánto mide este
ángulo y conozco la media de este otro
ángulo está en un triángulo como puedes
ver este triángulo así que no puedo
averiguar este ángulo claro que si puedo
porque es suplementario es suplementario
a este otro ángulo de 115 grados así que
así que bueno este ángulo es
y este ángulo morado más este ángulo
verde es igual a 180 180 mil 115 es
igual a 65 grados cierto esto es igual a
65 grados y que hemos hecho hasta el
momento estas son líneas paralelas
entonces ángulos correspondientes son
iguales este ángulo de 56 grados igual a
este ángulo de 56 grados luego dijimos
bueno bueno creo que perfecto este
ángulo verde más este ángulo morado es
igual a 180 y éste mide 115 el 65 y
ahora sabemos que o bueno conocemos dos
ángulos de este triángulo y si conocemos
los ángulos de un triángulo podemos
conocer el tercer ángulo porque la suma
de los ángulos internos de un triángulo
es igual a 180 así que ya vemos a este
ángulo x entonces aquí le voy a poner
esto es igual a equis y sabemos que x
más 56 grados más 65 grados es igual a
180 grados entonces
x 56 65 cuánto exceso soy mal haciendo
cuentas así que en 5 610 es creo que 121
si no me equivoco 121 grados luego x
entonces esto es igual a 180 grados
luego x es igual a 180 180 menos 121 es
igual a 59 grados y ahí lo tenemos hemos
llegado a nuestra primera meta entonces
en el juego de los ángulos ya llegamos a
lo primero que queríamos llegar así que
ahora hagamos un problema un tanto un
poco más difícil algo algo un poco más
desafiante vale así que el que haremos a
continuación no involucra líneas
paralelas veamos aquí voy a borrar
primero esta nueva pantalla entonces
veamos por qué porque lo que haremos es
juntar todo el conocimiento que tenemos
sobre líneas paralelas y ángulos y lo
que haremos es involucrar una estrella
en este problema así que voy aquí hacer
una estrella con la herramienta de línea
está la estrella casi casi todavía no le
faltan otras dos otros dos picos y
ahí está la estrella entonces que
sabemos sobre esto sabemos que sabemos
que este ángulo este ángulo mide 75
grados ajá y también este mide 75 grados
sabemos que este ángulo este grande mide
101 grados y tu misión en este juego de
los ángulos es averiguar este ángulo a
cuánto mide cuánto mide este ángulo este
de aquí ahora es un buen momento para
poner pausa el vídeo porque te voy a
mostrar la solución así que qué podemos
hacer
veamos juguemos con los ángulos y veamos
qué podemos averiguar si este ángulo
mide 101 grados que otros ángulos
podemos averiguar o saber cuánto miden a
partir de ese bueno podemos averiguar
este ángulo cierto porque es
suplementario entonces este ángulo como
el suplementario el ángulo de 101 grados
mide 79 grados y también éste mide 79
grados ahora este ángulo es opuesto al
de 101 grados entonces también mide 101
grados este de aquí 101 grados
qué más podemos saber a partir de esto
podemos averiguar este ángulo podemos
vemos que aquí hay un triángulo cierto
entonces entonces este triángulo este
ángulo este de aquí más
estos dos ángulos la suma es igual a 180
grados
así que llamemos a este ángulo b ajá
entonces ve más 75 más 75 es igual a 180
grados por lo tanto ve este triángulo de
aquí ahora ve más 150 es igual a 180 y
de aquí tenemos que ver es igual a 30
grados y ahora bien tú tú qué harías si
yo te digo que ya estamos listos para
averiguar cuánto mide este ángulo
amarillo qué genial no es súper genial
entonces vamos a hacer esto veamos te
voy a dar una pista vale
mira observa observa este triángulo este
triángulo grande a mejor lo voy a poner
con un color más visible un color rojo
observa este triángulo te lo digo que lo
más difícil de estos problemas es mirar
el triángulo adecuado y ver qué ok
genial perfecto porque se puede resolver
cualquier problema que se presente se
puede resolver entonces observa este
triángulo sabemos que este ángulo mide
101 grados y que acá y bueno acabamos de
ver que este mide 30 grados lo único que
debemos averiguar es cuánto mide el
triángulo amarillo pero que ya vemos de
equis y tenemos que x tenemos entonces x
más 101 grados más 30 grados es igual a
180 porque la suma de los ángulos
internos de un triángulo es igual a 180
entonces de esto tenemos que x es igual
a 49 grados cierto y ahí lo tienes hemos
terminado en el segundo problema en el
juego de los ángulos espero te haya
gustado
para mí fue muy divertido nos vemos
pronto bye